in our last two episodes we'll learn how
to manage gke infrastructure
and the individual services running on
it but as our applications become more
complex
more services are involved in serving
user traffic and completing transactions
it then becomes more and more critical
to understand how requests traverse
multiple services
and how each service contributes to
overall latency this is what distributed
tracing does
it captures the latency of user requests
and how long it takes each service in
the path to return a response
today i'm going to show you how to
capture latency in distributed
applications
using open telemetry and analyze it
using cloudtrace
welcome to engineering for reliability
with google cloud
[Music]
let's start by reviewing the basics of
distributed tracing these were
originally described in google's
research paper on the dapper distributed
tracing framework
we'll link to it below if you'd like to
read it when the user request comes in
we want to create a trace that will
describe how our system responds
traces are composed of spans where each
span represents a specific request and
response pair involved in serving the
original user request
the parent span describes the latency as
observed by the end user
each of the child spans describes how a
particular service in the distributed
system was called and responded
with latency information captured for
each now
let's take a look at a basic example we
have a front-end service that responds
to user requests
and makes calls to a back-end service it
has to wait on that back-end call to
complete to return the response back to
the user
we want to trace this interaction to
understand both total latency
and latency in each service we recommend
that you use open telemetry for
distributed tracing
it's an open source project that
provides a single set of apis
libraries agents and collector services
to capture distributed traces and
metrics from your application
let's have a look at how to instrument
your code for tracing we'll also link to
the full code sample in the episode
notes
we start by setting up the cloudtrace
exporter this will let us send the
traces we collect to cloud trace for
inspection
and analysis in the front end code we
start tracing and create the root span
we then make a request to the backend
with the appropriate context
this is data embedded in the http
headers that our background can use to
append subsequent spans to our trades
in the backend code we extract the
contacts from the incoming request
to create additional spans this allows
us to explicitly measure the latency of
our backend service
and create custom spans if for example
we want to time how long specific
back-end tasks might take
now let's run the code and have a look
at how we can use cloudtrace
to inspect request latency for both
incoming user requests and back-end
calls
from the project dashboard let's go to
the products menu and select trace
the trace list shows us all the traces
that have been captured in our project
over the selected time interval
let's switch that to the last day
then let's filter for the traces for
just incoming requests
for our frontend service using the label
that we set in our code
next let's select a relevant trace from
the resulting list
this shows us the waterfall chart with
the parent span at the top
and all of the child spans below that we
can see the latency for each span in the
chart to quickly determine the source of
the latency in our application overall
to get more information we can enable
events these are annotations we've added
in our code to more easily understand
exactly what's happening at each span
finally we can click on any of the spans
to get details for it over here on the
right
this is how we can use cloud trace to
analyze both the overall latency of user
requests
and how they traverse our services to
find the primary contributors to latency
issues
thanks for joining me today we covered
the basics of distributed tracing
and saw how to use open telemetry to
collect traces
we then saw how to use cloud trace to
inspect traces and analyze latency
i hope this helps you keep your services
fast and your users happy
thanks so much for watching don't forget
to like and subscribe to never miss out
on more
engineering for reliability with google
cloud see you soon